jamais un policier n'avait été en
détention provisoire aussi longtemps le
policier auteur du tir mortel sur naë
vient d'être libéré sous contrôle
judiciaire après plus de 4 mois en
cellule il était incarcéré depuis le 29
juin après de nombreux refus les juges
ont finalement accepté la demande de son
avocat estimant que les critères de la
détention provisoire n'était plus
remplie selon le parquet de nanère sa
détention provisoire a atteint un record
de longévité dans une affaire de
violence policière selon une source
proche de l'enquête il y a eu un réel
débat juridique sur les critères de
cette détention provisoire Naël 17 ans
avait été tué par ce policier en juin
dernier après un refus d'obtempéré à
nanre ce policier est donc toujours mis
en examen pour homicide volontaire mais
il est désormais libre sous contrôle
judiciaire selon l'article 144 du code
de procédure pénale la détention
provisoire doit être prononcée à titre
exceptionnel sous plusieurs conditions
dont notamment si elle constitue
l'unique moyen de conserver des preuves
nécessaires si elle peut empêcher une
pression sur les témoins ou les victimes
ou empêcher une concertation frauduleuse
entre le mise en examen et ses
co-auteurs et enfin si elle peut
garantir le maintien du mise en examen
main à la disposition de la justice les
4 mois en prison semblent injustifié au
regard d'Éric Henry le délégué national
d'alliance police dans la mesure où il
n'existait aucun risque de pression sur
les victimes et que toutes les garanties
de représentation étaient réunies
autrement dit que le policier n'allait
pas disparaître une fois relâché selon
le syndicat cette mesure a uniquement
été motivée par la colère de l'opinion
publique c'était un moyen de rétablir la
paix sociale pendant plusieurs nuits
consécutive après la mort de Naël de
nombreuses villes avaient été marquées
par de violentes émeutes urbaines la
mère de Naël quant à elle a appelé un
rassemblement ce dimanche après avoir
appris la libération du
[Musique]
policier